So earlier this week
We had a discussion about the narcissism of minor differences and I explained that it's really important on the one hand not to ignore.
Significant political differences between people between candidates on issues,
but at the same time we want to make sure that we don't fall into a trap of making
relatively small differences into a bigger deal than they need to be at the possible risk of hurting our own movements.
This was in the context of not just the 2020 election, but we talked about that and it turns out that it was extraordinarily
timely for me to talk about that at the beginning of the week.
Because this is very quickly becoming a real issue in the 2020 primary now that we have more
serious contenders for the 2020 Democratic nomination there are multiple overlapping disinformation
campaigns that are in full swing.
Specifically to divide the left some are more coordinated than others.
Others are sort of more ad hoc or de-facto
disinformation campaigns and I'm going to tell you what's going on and who is doing it is a little bit less clear right now.
Although we are learning more and more about that every single day. So the first question is who is primarily being targeted
by these disinformation campaigns and it's primarily
Kamala Harris,
Elizabeth Warren, Bernie Sanders and interestingly
Beto O'Rourke who's not actually even a declared candidate right now.
He's not even said that he's running for president in 2020.
Those are the primary four targets of these disinformation campaigns. The campaigns are
primarily happening on Twitter
reddit, they are stemming partially from 4chan and are also visible on YouTube as well as
just in the comment sections of news websites that are reporting on these campaigns and possible campaigns.
Tactics that are being used. These will be familiar to many of you.
Tactic number one.
Distort the positions of candidates so that comparing them
becomes more difficult because you're comparing them based on false notions as to what their positions are tactic number one.
Tactic number two.
Spread
insulting memes, ad homonyms and some in some cases they're not even really ad homonyms in the sense that they are
argument critiques on the basis of personal characteristics. Sometimes they're just insults not connected to any particular policy. Number three.
Foment hashtags that are critical and or insulting of the candidates
using a specific cluster of accounts that has been identified by a number of different data trackers online.
In the specifics in the particulars
a lot of these campaigns are racially oriented. One example for just to give you one data point
was the idea that in, remember that New Year's Eve?
Roughly around New Year's, Eve Elizabeth Warren's Instagram stream where she had a beer?
One of the false claims was that she had visible during that stream a
blackface doll in the background. It simply wasn't true
and this was used to try to start creating racial tensions around Elizabeth Warren's campaign for example. Now
before people email me
angrily saying, "No, no David. Those weren't BOTS or coordinated campaigns or shills. That was me.
I'm not a bot.
I genuinely thought, I don't know, Elizabeth Warren had a blackface doll on camera behind her." That may be true, but that doesn't
counteract the reality that a number of these data science firms including guardians AI has
specifically identified a cluster of accounts that are posting and
amplifying certain memes and stories in a very coordinated effort.
There are accounts that are the same accounts identified as spreading misinformation
during the 2018
midterm run up and participating in a lot of the same stuff and
shockingly 2 to 15% of all Twitter mentions of some of these candidates
originated from this cluster of only
200 accounts. Which is just an
incredibly small number to be responsible for this amount of
the memes and disinformation, and then of course,
they become amplified by a broader group of accounts. According to one analysis about 10,000 accounts then further amplifying these
disinformation
messages. So far this could be because of when she announced, Kamala Harris,
has been targeted the most with both a sexist and racist messages.
Beto O'Rourke was accused of using racist language in an answering machine message years and years ago.
When Elizabeth Warren announced there was a ton of bots like activity on Facebook and Twitter
targeting her. A lot of it originated on 4chan and 8chan.
So I think the important thing to keep in mind here, Pat, is that this is not entirely
coordinated. There are some identifiable
discreet efforts to focus on one candidate or another candidate. The total impact of this, the
coordinated and the more ad hoc stuff. The problem with it is that it's spreading false information. That's not good
but it has the effect of not just pitting Democratic voters against each other in an unproductive way.
It's pitting Democratic voters against each other on the basis of false stories, and that's why it's so dangerous.
Yeah, and I don't know if you would call this fake news per se,
but if it's not, it's very similar and you know
Donald Trump was the primary beneficiary of fake news back in
2016. Ironic because he always seems to rail against it even though he's talking about, when he talks about fake news.
It's really just news that he disagrees with story run by the New York Times or The Washington Post or what have you.
What have you it looks like he may be the primary beneficiary again of fake news in 2020.
Every indication that at least so far that would be the net effect of this carried to it's sort of full conclusion.
We have every indication that some of this is foreign, but some of it is domestic and some of it is coming from
Democratic partisans who are trying to sort of preemptively discredit particular candidates before the Democratic primary
really even gets going in earnest with debates and and the like. The most depressing part of all of this for me
is that this stuff works, right? If the landscape that we had
were one where disinformation
didn't spread.
Wasn't effective we really wouldn't have to worry about this so much but this stuff works. We've got
Anti-vaxxers, people who deny climate change, we have people who believe the most outrageous things and fall for the silliest disinformation.
Yes,
they exist more on the right but this stuff actually matters and it impacts the left and we've got to stay on top of it.
One of the days sponsors is privacy dot-com slash
Pakman. Which is a free service that I myself use.
Really useful in many different ways takes just a few seconds to link your debit card to privacy com.
Then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to your bank account and you use those virtual credit card numbers to buy things online.
Which protects your actual debit card so that it's not
spread all over the internet and one of the best things about it is how their mobile app and browser extensions for Chrome and Firefox
make it really easy to use.
Let's say for example, that I'm signing up for a David Pakman show membership. In the credit card number field
I already see the privacy dot com icon.
I
just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want to use and the credit card number, expiration date and security code are
automatically entered. I can put in any zip code I want and I'm done, and if you try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen,
it doesn't matter because I've already deleted that virtual card.
And that's the beauty of privacy dot com.
There are a ton of advantages to using a free service like this.
For example, you can sign up for as many free trials as you want then just delete the virtual credit card
you used and never worry about getting charged for it. It protects you from getting hacked.
It protects you when companies are hacked which happens all the time. It is all completely free.
All you have to do is click the link under this video to get started and for a limited time.
They're giving everyone in our audience $5 towards your first purchase when you sign up using that link.